how many companies is Elon Musk running
at this point right between obviously
Twitter Tesla space asks neural link
starlink the boring company the tunnel
company that he does
um open AI I'm just these are things
that are coming to mind how does he what
kind of bandwidth neurolink what kind of
bandwidth do you need to have I mean
you're a guy who's running multiple
companies I see how much
how you're divvy up your schedule like I
have a hard time just balancing two
companies plus a personal life how does
someone like Elon Musk balance all of
this
I think a long time ago he chose career
over like priority in life to him he
feels his cause is more worthy of him
going up against these types of enemies
versus I don't know if father is number
one on his list I don't know if husband
is number one on his list I don't know
if those things are number one on his
list I think he seems himself as a
warrior Crusader genius he's building
what he's building he does believe in
procreation because he's got a lot of
kids he's got like 10 kids or something
so so his his kids are his businesses so
if you treated your businesses as your
kids because kids are very taxing
they're very demanding so if you have
four kids and you got four businesses it
is very hard to race four kids it is
very hard to race four businesses you
have to kind of pick and choose which
one you're going to be doing he says
he's at the office seven days a week 18
hours a day 24 hours a day he's sleeping
there what he's saying is I'm also not
spending time with the kids I'm spending
time my kids that's Twitter that's this
that's that so yeah you can do that if
you choose to treat your companies like
your kids and that's what he's doing but
you're basically sacrificing a
relationship with your kids everything
in life you're gonna have to at one
point uh uh on a when you're on a run of
obsession you're sacrificing all these
athletes we admire that you follow Kobe
Bryant's sacrifice personal time with
his family 20 years of playing 82 games
41 on the road playoffs Olympics you
think that's a peaceful life military
generals General Mattis we admire
35-year service you know he's in you
know War for you think you're you're a
good father I haven't seen my kid nine
years out of the last 18 years my kid
was you know at the house I was at War I
was on you think that's you put that as
a great father what do you how do you
describe that so the definition of all
of these things it's very to him his
mind is if these generals are at War
doing what they're doing I'm simply
doing my war in business competing
against these guys and I see my kids
where I take them place and we have a
good time but I'm like like the general
that's at War I don't see my kids for a
year and a half or a year I see myself
same as that I think that's his
processing and I don't think he sees
anything wrong with that and I think a
lot of people that have competed at that
level at that crazy level say yeah
that's what you got to do you know when
you're running for office like John F
Kennedy ran for office when he was how
old early 40s what do you think his life
looked like he was the youngest
president no 43 how old was the guy when
he became president not on 42 40 42 43
youngest ever because I mean the Obama
and Clinton are right behind him right
right at 47 or 40 or something like that
what do you think you're doing when
you're campaigning for two years
you you don't think your kids in second
grade he has kids that are under his
desk the pictures those are not 20 year
old kids these are you know what do you
think it is when your Hollywood star
Denzel Washington you're going out there
doing movies where this guy was in
Sicily for uh how long were you in
Sicily shooting uh three weeks okay
that's three weeks away from 17 19 and a
20 year old yeah that's a that's not you
know so these these types of performers
at that level there comes with a
sacrifice but the the the average person
will look at that and say oh my gosh
that's terrible but the peak Peak
performers at the top will sit there and
say yeah that's kind of what you got to
do it's by the way neither side can sell
it to the other side it's purely a
choice
neither side can sell it to the other
side and that's a great point I think on
behalf of Americans and behalf of
humanity I think we're all thankful that
he is sacrificing his family life but
you know you do see these stories that
one of his kids came out and disowned
his father and he's not my father and he
might be some sort of trans situation
with one of the kids I don't know what
that story is but you're familiar with
the story right one of the kids
basically disavowed so these are the
types of sacrifices you're making that
your kids won't even love you or they'll
disapp value or disown you because you
have such lofty goals that there is you
know risks and rewards to everything
he's doing or your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign